[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنها شخص ديناميكي
لمجرد أنها كانت قادرة
على اختراق النظام السياسي في الولايات
المتحدة وأن تكون أول
امرأة عربية أمريكية مسلمة يتم انتخابها لمنصب
مندوب الدولة على مستوى الدولة ثم
بناءً على خدمتها وما
أنجزته ، تمكنت من التفوق
بسبب شخصيتها ودينامياتها
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
ترعرعت مع أمها أصغر ، لقد
فعلت كل شيء
مع المساعدة في تربيتنا وأيضًا
مع المدرسة
والطهي والعودة إلى المنزل
وقد أثرت حقًا على حياتنا كلها ، أعني
أنها فعلت ذلك كله مع
التعليم المدرسي
للتأكد من أننا نعتني بها
فهي تتمتع بهذه الروح المذهلة التي هي عليها
إنها مدهشة ، إنها معلمة عظيمة
رائعة ، أخت مدهشة لقد كانت آنا
[موسيقى]
هي
تريد تقديم شكوى لك يا قطك
[موسيقى]
المساواة في الكرامة الإنسانية في
مكان العمل كل هؤلاء  الأشياء ما
يجعلنا  أقل استحقاقًا لما
لأننا ولدنا فقراء ، عليك أن تستمر في
التحدث وقول لا والرد لأنه
إذا لم يكن هناك أي شخص يمكن أن يكون هناك
رشيدة أخرى في المجتمع أو عضوة الكونغرس التالية إن
شاء الله الرئيس
من ديترويت آه
هذا يستمع ويخبرها شخص ما
لا ، لا يمكنك فعل هذا ، فأنت لا
تستحق هذا
، سنقاتل من أجل الجميع وليس فقط شركات
[الموسيقى]
القليلة التي تحكم على كل شيء
، وكانت تقاتل بشدة من أجل كلية الحقوق ، ولا
بد لي من الحصول على هذه الدرجة
للقيام بذلك.  سأحصل على هذه الدرجة
لأفعل ذلك
لأنني كنت أعلم أن ذلك
سيمنحني القوة للقتال من
أجل شعبي
[موسيقى
] أجنبيًا ، أعلم أنها ليست حفلة مثالية وليست كذلك
ولكن الحفلة هي التي فتحت
الباب أمامي
الترشح لمنصب لم يحدث أبدًا
بسرعة ، لقد كان
الموعد النهائي 10 أيام ،
أنت تعرف
سيدي
، النظام معطل للغاية ، المجلس
التشريعي معطل للغاية ،
هل سيرون حقًا شعبي
إذا كنت موجودًا
هناك الحمد لله ذهبت إلى
هناك وفجأة
أنت لا  لا أعيش هناك
، وأقول لك أنك مخطئ ، هذا
ما يحدث لأطفالهم مصابين
بالربو لأنكم تقولون أنه لا بأس
أن أطفالهم يذهبون إلى المدارس
حيث يتسرب السقف وأنت تقول
إنه بخير ولكنك  قل ، حسنًا ، لماذا لا
يستطيعون العمل لأنك لا
تمنحهم فرصًا للحصول
على نفس الحياة ولكن بنوعية حياة جيدة في
نفس الأحياء والمدارس
نفسها ، نفس الحدائق التي تقولها لأطفالك
بدأت في الوثوق بي
وأنا لا أفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف شيئًا عن شيفيلد إيشياني أو أن
شيئًا ما سيكون مختلفًا
معها ، ماذا عن ستيف جوبمان
نعم
جنوب غرب ديترويت
[موسيقى] من
أي وقت مضى كنت تعرف مسلمًا انتخب من قبل
أول
مجتمع مسلمة يشتري
[موسيقى] ،
لذا فإن الخسارة في عام 2014 كانت
مدمرة
لقد تحطم قلبي ،
كان الأمر كما لو أن شخصًا ما أخذ مهمتي
بعيدًا عني لأنني كنت أعمل لمدة ست
سنوات في منزل الولاية لم أنتهي ،
وكان لدي الكثير من العمل لأقوم به بشأن
حقوق المهاجرين في مجال العدالة البيئية التي
كنت أعمل عليها  كل هذه القضايا
المتعلقة بالفقر والأطفال يفعلون ما كان عليه من
قبل بعد التمويل
المدرسي ،
ولذا عندما خسرت كان الأمر مدمرًا
اعتقدت أنني انتهيت ، لم أفكر مطلقًا في
أنني سأقوم بالترشح لأي شيء
آخر تعرف أنه كان بعد سنوات
عندما
كان العضو  من الكونغرس لم نعتقد أبدًا
أنه سيحدث ، لكنه تقاعد
بعد 53 عامًا ،
جون كونيرز الأسطوري ولذا لم أفكر مطلقًا في أنني
سأتبع خطاه وأترشح للكونغرس
،
وحتى عندما قررنا
كمجتمعي وأنا أتينا جميعًا  معًا
وقلنا ربما هذا هو السبب في
أنك ربما تحتاج إلى الترشح للكونغرس
وكان ذلك أيضًا بسبب من كان الرئيس
في ذلك الوقت
لا أعرف ما إذا كنت سأترشح للكونغرس
إذا لم يكن الرئيس الذي تم عزله إلى الأبد
هناك
أفكر حقًا في الأمر طوال الوقت ،
وأعتقد أنه إذا كان رئيسًا مختلفًا ،
فهل سيكون لدي هذا الدافع للذهاب والقتال ،
لكني أحب الاستمرار في قيادتي والتفكير في
داخلي هو
أنني لا أستطيع السماح له
بإخبار مجتمعي بأنهم  "  أقل
من كل شيء كنا نقاتله
لأنه لا يهتم بنا
ولا يمكنني الجلوس على الهامش ، ولا
بد لي من العودة للقتال
[موسيقى]
مرة أخرى
فعالة جدًا
من كل شيء  لقد فعلنا
ذلك من باب إلى باب وجهاً لوجه ، لقد
علمت أن هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة
التي تعرف بها أن الكثير من المرشحين الذين يترشحون
للكونغرس يقومون بعمل لوحات إعلانية هذه
الملصقات الكبيرة في المجتمع
في Dayat altilvision ،
قمنا بتوظيف أشخاص من
المجتمع وقلنا
هيا  اذهب مع rasheeda واذهب إلى
الأبواب ودائمًا أقول للناس ،
أنا فخور جدًا بأن أكون قادرًا على
ارتداء حذائي الرياضي مثل أي شخص آخر وذهبت وطرقت الأبواب كان الناس خائفين جدًا
يا إلهي
لأننا لم نفعل ذلك  لم نتمكن من الذهاب إلى
الجميع ،
لقد جربنا شارع ألين
[موسيقى]
عبر
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين
لتقرير مصيرهم
وتصميمهم وهم يتجهون نحو دولة واحدة
أكثر مما تعلمون يدعمون ذلك ولكني
كنت أعرف حل الدولتين أه
في هذا الموقف القوي الذي كان لديهم
لم يتطابقوا لكنهم
ما زلت أعمل معهم كثيرًا ، فهم
يوافقون على أن لديّ عدسة ومنظورًا فريدًا
حول
ما يحدث في تافه ، لدينا
علاقة عمل جيدة لكنهم يعلمون
أنني لا أعتقد أن هناك  المسار ،
أعني أن شخصًا ما يمكن أن يوضح لي كيف ،
لكن لا أعتقد أن هناك طريقًا لحل
الدولتين مع نظام الفصل العنصري
الذي يحدث في إسرائيل الآن ،
أعني أنه يبدو
مستحيلًا جدًا بالنسبة لي ، إنه مختلف تمامًا
حتى عندما  آخر مرة كنت هناك
وما أراه وأسمعه من
الأصوات الفلسطينية على الأرض
هو أنهم يريدون أن يكونوا
في المركز ، يجب أن تكون أصواتهم
في قلب تقرير مصيرهم.
الحب
الذي يعيش
في الاحتلال غير الشرعي في إسرائيل ،
لديّهم تجربتي ، فأنا أحمل كل
ذلك ،
ولا أعرف ماذا أخبرهم
بخلاف هذه هذه هي
قصتي عن سلفي عن عائلتي وأنا
أحضرها معي
اه ال  الخلافات لا تتوقف عند هذا الحد
فهم يختلفون معي في التلوث فهم
يختلفون معي في الرعاية الصحية
غير مألوف أه مع حقيقة أن لدي
وجهة نظر تبدو غير محببة
أم تعرف الإدارة السابقة
حتى الإدارة الحالية
كلا الإدارتين التي تعتبر
جمهورية واحدة  شخص ديمقراطي ،
أنت تعرف أن هذه المساعدة غير المشروطة
تنظر بعيدًا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بقيم حقوق الإنسان لبلد ما ولكن
ليس الآخر
بالنسبة لي ،
عندما يكون هناك شيء خاطئ ،
يُقتل الناس حرفيًا لمجرد
أنهم ولدوا فلسطينيين
[موسيقى]
أجنبيًا
هذا ليس  الأولى ولن تكون
آخر مرة نسمع فيها لغة متعصبة مثيرة للاشمئزاز
من
رئيس الكونجرس ،
لذلك أريد أن أخبرك أنك تعرف
بالنسبة لي ارتداء الزي الفلسطيني رغم
أنك تعرف أن الكثير من الناس لا
يدركون أن والدتي ولدت فيها  صغيرة
ولكن في جواز سفرها الأمريكي يقول إنها ولدت في
الأردن لم تولد قط في الأردن ،
ولدت في تافه وأردت
أن أعطي درجة البكالوريوس.  ck لها ولكني أردت أيضًا
أن أمثل نفسي بشكل غير اعتذاري ،
هذا هو
أنا كثير من الناس في المجتمع
أه تعلم أن المجتمع العربي الأمريكي
قال
إنه لا يجب عليك ارتداء هذا على الرغم من
أنك لا تعرف الكثير على
الفور وأنا  قلت لا ، أنا فلسطيني منذ اليوم
الأول وأم فخور بفخر فلسطيني أمريكي
وأمك تعرف
ولدين مسلمين في
أمريكا ، ابنة مهاجرين
فخورة وابنة لعامل في جامعة واشنطن ،
كل هذه الأشياء ماي مصرية
ولذا أردت أن  تمثل ذلك
وبالنسبة لي ، فأنت تعرف القسم الكامل
على القرآن ، أعني أنه رمز ،
ليس هذا هو الطريقة التي تؤدي بها اليمين حقًا ،
ولكنه كان رمزًا ولا
أعلم أنني أردت مشاركة
جميع الأطفال في جميع أنحاء البلاد.
العالم الذي يراك يمكن أن يكون الشخص الذي
تريده مهما حاولوا أن يقولوا
إننا أقل من
أو الصور النمطية المستمرة حول من نحن
من التافهين
انظر إليها إنها تأتي من هذه
المدينة القوية الجميلة هذه جميلة ب  تفتقر إلى مدينة
ديترويت وهناك هي
لا تخفيها تمامًا
وأردت أن يراها الجميع ، وأتمنى أن يروا ذلك الجميع ،
وأتمنى إن شاء الله
أن يستلهموا منه
مؤتمر [الموسيقى].
تلقيت تهديدات بالقتل من
قبل أه ولكن هذا كان ساحقًا ،
فأنت تعلم أنني أصبحت وجهك وأنا أعلم أنني
أريد توجيه الاتهام إلى هذا
الرئيس بسبب أنشطته غير القانونية ،
ولم أكن خجولًا من
مدى
خيبة أملك وغاضبًا
وفزعًا لأنك تعلم
أنني محامي وأعتقد ذلك  علينا
التمسك بدستور الولايات المتحدة
حتى أنني طلبت من الرئيس هل
قرأته من قبل
وأنت تعلم أنني قلت إننا بحاجة إلى عزله
حتى قبل أن يفعل ما فعله في
أوكرانيا كان يدير أعماله
من البيت الأبيض من المكتب البيضاوي
وهذا مخالف لدستور الولايات
المتحدة ، وإذا سمحنا له بفعل ذلك ، فما هو
الملياردير التالي الذي سيأتي
ويريد أن يكون رئيسًا للولايات المتحدة؟
لم تكن أعماله مصلحة في مصلحة
الأشخاص الذين من المفترض أن يقاتل من
أجلهم ويمثلهم ،
لذلك أعلم أنه جاء التحدي المتمثل في
كل هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين وقفوا معه ،
كما تعلمون ،
فقط على كره لا هوادة فيه
جاء نحوي لذلك  طبقة
فوق كل الأشخاص الذين كانوا
يشبهونها طبقة مسلمة
تؤمن فوقها بما هي حرة
طبقة فلسطين الحرة فوق ذلك ،
فأنت تعلم كل الأشياء التي وقفت عليها في
أول يوم لي من التوجيه ، لقد
حصلت على موتي الأول  التهديد
لقد كان أمرًا خطيرًا ، لقد
أخذوني جانبًا ، وكان على مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي الذهاب إلى منزل الرجل النبيل ،
ولم أقم حتى بأداء اليمين حتى الآن
عندما يكون
هناك بعض الحقيقة في ذلك ، أعتقد تمامًا
أن
الرئيس السابق
هو انعكاس
لتغيير الحزب الجمهوري
و  التحرك نحو أعني
هؤلاء هم هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين يقولون إننا
لا نريد تعليم
تاريخ الأمريكيين الأفارقة
يريدون محو أن الرئيس السابق
يعكس الآن
مدى
تطرفهم.
أي من الأعضاء الجمهوريين
يحصلون عليه فيما يتعلق ببعض هذه
المواقف ، إنه أمر خطير
للغاية ومؤسف إذا كنت تعتقد
أنك تعرف الأخت إيلانا عمر
وأنت تعلم أنها لاجئة ، أنا ابنة
مهاجرين
تعرف أنها تأتي من ذلك  عشت
التجربة وتقول تتحدث عنها ،
أتيت وأقول إنني نشأت في ديترويت
وهذا ما علمتني إياه حركة الحقوق المدنية
وما تفعله هو ضدك تمامًا
تعرف تكريم هذا التاريخ ولذا
أعتقد أن كل ذلك يأتي لذا فهو ليس كذلك
دائمًا ما يتعلق
الأمر بقضية التلميذ ، فليس
دائمًا موضوع
أه حتى الفرقة المسلمة ، إنها
طبقات وطبقات أخرى من الجذور
حيث يأتي كل هذا من هذا
الطالب ،
لا توجد طريقة هي من أجل
قيم شعب ميشيغان ولكن  لقد
شاهدتها هذا الصباح
إنها شريرة
إنها مثل مجنون مجنون عندما أتذكر
أن قلبي يغرق فقط
وأول ما يتبادر إلى ذهني هو
حول هذه
اللقطة وآمل ألا  لا يمكن لبلدنا أن يأخذ
فترة أخرى
من وجود شخص ما يروج
لهجوم التفوق الأبيض على ديمقراطيتنا.
لا أعرف سوى أن أخبرك
أنك تعلم أنني مستعد لمحاربة أي شخص
يحاول أن يأتي بعد مجتمعي يمكنني
أن أقول  لك ، سيكون
مؤلمًا للغاية أن نرى ذلك يحدث
مرة أخرى
[موسيقى]
وكل ما نراه هو العكس تمامًا
لدينا نظام الفصل العنصري الآن ، لا أعرف كيف
نحقق ذلك ، ولا أعرف كيف
نفعل ذلك عندما نستمر في الفصل
المجتمعات من بعضها البعض
و ashananam
كما تعلمون تعلمت من
الفصل العنصري في حركة الحقوق المدنية لا يعمل أنت تعيش هنا
أنت تعيش هنا لا يعمل ، لقد تعلمت
مبكرًا من تجربتي الخاصة
التي لا تعمل منفصلة ولكن متساوية
وهذا هو السبب  لقد اتخذت هذا الموقف ،
لكنني قلت باستمرار
إنني أريد أن أرى التنظيم وأريد
أن أرى الناس على الأرض ، وأريد
أن تركز أصواتهم على الأشخاص
الذين تم انتخابهم وليسوا أعضاء في الكونغرس
على طول الطريق.  الموظفون المتحدون
يجب أن يكون الأشخاص
الأكثر تأثرًا على الأرض هم الذين يجب أن يقرروا
، وأنا أعرف المزيد والمزيد من
الفلسطينيين على
وجه التحديد أه
أنت تعرف
الأمهات والآخرين الذين تحدثت إليهم
فقط لا يرون طريقًا بخلاف
كل شخص يعيش معًا في بعض  نوع من
الطريقة التي يتمتع فيها الجميع بالمساواة ، أحاول
التحدث عن ذلك مع زملائي
بهذه الطريقة حتى يفهموا من أين
يأتي هذا المنظور إذا كنت
تدعم الدولتين ، فعليك
التحدث ضد الفصل
العنصري وأعتقد دائمًا أنهم يريدون ذلك  نفس الشيء ،
نريد نفس الأشياء ،
فكيف نصل إلى هناك دائمًا مختلف
، يعتقدون أنه بهذه الطريقة وأنت تعرف
نفسي لا أستطيع أن أقول للجميع في
الحزب الديمقراطي ،
أعتقد أن الأمر يتعلق بوضع الناس قبل
أن
تستمع الشركات إليهم بوضعهم باهتمام.
أولاً ، ضع الاستثمار فيها
أولاً
، ثم قد تكون الشركات
والقطاعات والصناعة
الأخرى في المرتبة الثانية أو الثالثة ، لكن إذا فعلت
ذلك ، أعتقد أن النتيجة ستكون
هائلة بالنسبة للناس.
لكني أشعر كثيرًا أنني أعتقد أن الجمهوريين
يحبون أن يتبعوا نهجًا مختلفًا
حيث اعتمادًا على الأشخاص الذين
يأتون قبلهم والذين سيستمعون إلى
أحد الأشياء التي كنت أحاول
القيام بها هو إضفاء الطابع الإنساني
على الأم
التي قالت
أنت تعلم أنها تنام مع أطفالها
لأنها لا تعرف أنها
ستكون قادرة على الاستيقاظ ، كما تعلم إذا كنا
سنموت فلنموت معًا
للتعبير عن
معنى رؤية طفلك مدفونًا على قيد الحياة أو
طفلة أُخذت تحت
الأنقاض وشاهدت
والديها يموتان هناك
يأخذان أنفاسهما الأخيرة
ولذا أعلم
أنه أثر على بلدي ،
أعتقد
أن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية لم
تسمع
هذا الصوت في الكونجرس
أبدًا وأعتقد أنه كان كثيرًا  هناك حاجة لذلك حتى
لو لم أغير قلوب
وعقول زملائي ، آمل أن أغير
قلوب وعقول جيراني في جميع
أنحاء البلاد الذين يمكنهم رؤية أن هناك تكلفة
مدمرة
تكلفتها البشرية لاستمرار بلدنا
لدعمك وتمويلك
بالسلاح بالمال ،
فهذه الأنواع
منكم تعرف حقوق الإنسان الدولية ، فأنت
تعلم أن
العديد من الانتهاكات قد أشرت إليها بالفعل على أنها
جرائم حرب حتى في البداية ،
لم يتحدث الكثير من زملائي علانية ، والآن
لا يتحدثون
أبدًا.  قبل أن ترى هذا النوع من الأشخاص ،
لا يمكنك أبدًا أن تتخيل أن هذا العدد الكبير من الأشخاص
يأتون إلى أرضية المنزل ليقولوا إنني
لن أدعم تمويل القبة الحديدية ،
لن أدعم
استمرار المساعدة غير المشروطة للأمة
لم يكن من الممكن أبدًا أن يتخيل الناس
أنها كانت حرفيًا
أه
القتل السياسي هذا حرفياً إذا
تحدثت ضد حقوق الإنسان في فلسطين
وأدانت انتهاكات الحكومة الإسرائيلية
وطلبت مساعدة
مشروطة لإسرائيل فلن يتم انتخابك مرة أخرى
وهذا نوع من الأسطورة الموجودة هناك
وقد تم تحطيم الأسطورة بالكامل
ومرة أخرى
بانتخابي أنا والعديد من
زملائنا الآخرين الذين يواصلون
التحدث ضد تلك الانتهاكات ،
أريد أن يفكر الجميع  للحظة
ما يعنيه العيش في منطقة صغيرة جدًا
حيث تقوم عشرات وعشرات الطائرات
بمهاجمة وتفجير ما يعنيه على
وجه الخصوص
لأطفال غزة
[موسيقى
] معاداة السامية
التي تعرفها الحركة لمحاولة
إسكاتي  هو أن أقول
كل ما أقوله وهو صادق
حول ما يحدث على الأرض
والذي يتم ترجمته بطريقة ما
مني من مكان الكراهية لا
أتحدث على وجه التحديد عن
التجربة الفلسطينية
حول انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان
حول التقارير الدولية لحقوق الإنسان
أنا أكرر
الكثير مما هو موجود بالفعل في العديد من
هذه
الدراسات واه أنت تعرف القصص التي
تستمر في
الظهور ولذا أتحدث عن الحقيقة وفي كل مرة
أتحدث فيها عن الحقيقة ،
لا يحبها الناس لذلك يريدون
محاولة إسكاتي  وكل ما يمكنني قوله هو
كل جيراني اليهود ولدي جيران يهود
أمثلهم
وأقاتل من أجلهم
يعلمون أنني قادم من
مكان محبوب وأنا لست على الإطلاق هذا ليس
من مكان
ضد أي شيء  هذا هو مكان
مؤيد لحقوق الإنسان مؤيد للعدالة مؤيد للمساواة
بغض النظر عمن هو المسيء ومن
هو الظالم الأم
هل تعلم أن الناس يراقبونني دائمًا هنا في
بلدنا وحتى وسائل الإعلام
تراقبني لماذا تفعل ذلك؟  هذا هو سبب قيامها بذلك ،
تذكر ما أقوله ،
تذكر ما أقف من أجله أنا واحد
من حفنة من الأشخاص الذين يتحدثون
ضد إسرائيل بطريقة قوية جدًا
دون خوف ، أحاول حرفيًا
سرد القصة وتركيز
كل شيء  ما أقوم به حول انتهاكات حقوق
الإنسان ليس فقط في التافه ،
بل في الكشمير أيضًا ، أتعرض للهجوم
لأننا أيضًا لا نعيش في عالم تويتر
مهما أضعه هناك في بعض الأحيان ،
لست متأكدًا من سبب يمكنني إزالته أو
أيا كان  لكنني أعلم أنني أريد أن
أركز دائمًا على كلماتي الفعلية ،
فأنت تعلم الإيمان بحقوق الإنسان أه
يقدر حزبي قيادة البيت الأبيض ،
الجميع يريد إسكاتي ،
لن يتم إسكاتي ، أعرف أن
ما فعلته  أمر لا يصدق لم أعد
لقد أصبحت في الواقع
أقوى وأكثر عدم اعتذار حيال ذلك
لأنني أشعر فقط أنه كلما زاد رد الفعل الذي
أستمر في الحصول عليه ، يجب أن
أفعل
الآن
هناك منظمة دعت
ألهان عمر بنفسي وحتى ستايسي
بلسكواد ورقم  من
أعضاء الكونجرس الآخرين
للحضور للقاء الفلسطينيين الإسرائيليين ، لقد جاءوا للتو
إلى البلاد للتعرف على
بعض النضالات والتحديات ، لذلك
بالنسبة لي ، كنت أفكر في
القدوم مبكرًا ليوم واحد للذهاب
أه وأرى مدينتي أه مافيا وبيتروثا
وأم
أنت تعلم بالطبع
أنه كانت هناك شائعات قبل أن نسمع
علنًا
أن رئيس وزراء إسرائيل نتنياهو
كان يفكر في عدم السماح لنا بالدخول
إلى البلد حيث
يأتي أعضاء الكونغرس الآخرون بحرية إلى
البلاد طوال الوقت ، فلماذا قال حسنًا
أقصد هذا  هو البيان الذي
قدموه بسبب موقفي من bds ، إنها
طريقة سلمية للرد على
انتهاكات حقوق الإنسان في إسرائيل
، ولذا لأنني من مؤيدي
حركة bds أم هذا هو نفس النوع من
الحركة التي أوقفت الفصل العنصري في
جنوب إفريقيا أه إنها نفس النوع من
الحركة التي تعلمت بها
عن حركة الحقوق المدنية هنا
ولذا
كان هذا هو السبب ولكني أعلم أنها
أيضًا متجذرة  في عدد من
المناصب الأخرى التي أمتلكها ،
لكنني شعرت بالدمار
بالنسبة لي ،
فقد أظهر للتو أنه يمكنني أن أكون
عضوًا في الولايات المتحدة في الكونغرس والحصول على
بلد حيث نعطي مليارات
الدولارات
ونمنع من دخول البلاد
وعلى
الرغم من أن البعض  وقف زملائي
معي بينما
لم تقل الدولة أبدًا
أننا ارتكبنا خطأ ، آسف تعال أو
نحاول حتى معالجته ، نحتاج إلى تغيير
سياساتنا عندما يتعلق الأمر
بدولة إسرائيل ، فنحن بحاجة ماسة إلى النظر إليها
للقيام بعمل مختلف  العدسة
لأنه من الواضح
أنك تعرف أنه لا يمكنك الادعاء بأنك
ديمقراطية ثم تقول أنك مواطن أمريكي
تعرف البلد الذي يقدم
لك أكبر قدر من المساعدة لا يمكنك القدوم إلى بلدنا
لأنك تدعم  هذه
القضايا وأنا أقوم بتدريس
أوكاسيو كورتيز تمامًا ،
كما تعلم ، اترك الذهاب إلى حيث تعرف ، أنا
مثل المكان الذي تتحدث عنه أنا
من ديترويت حيث تخبرني إلى أين
أذهب من حيث هانا أكيلو
[موسيقى]
نتنياهو
بالنسبة لي
ماذا  أخبرتني عائلتي الصغيرة أن
لديك مؤخرتك التي هي مجانية ، لقد
تجلى حلمنا
لماذا أتيت إلى هنا حتى يتمكنوا من
وضعك في قفص لأنهم يريدونني في الأساس
أن أوافق على التزام الصمت
حتى لا أذهب إلى هنا ولا أذهب إلى هناك.
حركة لا حرية في
التعبير
أه
وأنك تعلم أن الناس بحاجة إلى
فهم لعائلتي ، لقد تجلى حلمهم
أنا الطائر الحر ،
لماذا ستعود حتى يتمكنوا من
حبسك رشيدة وآياتما
[موسيقى]
نعم  سأنتظرك
حتى
تعرف إن شاء الله سألتقي
بها قبل
أنفاسها الأخيرة.
إنه مثلي متعاطف للغاية لكنه
كذلك  متورط في معرفة ما يمكن أن يفعله
يوسف أه يستخدمني ، أنت تعرف أنه موجود ،
لذا فهو يلعب وكل شيء لكنه
يعرف أيضًا أنه يقول لي
طوال الوقت
أه تعلم أنني أخبره
دائمًا بالكونغرس أحيانًا عندما أشعر بالضيق ،
أريد فقط  لكي يستقيل ، يذهب إلى ماما
ولكنك جيد في ذلك ، يجب أن تستمر في
فعلك لمساعدة الأشخاص الذين
تجيدهم ، وقلت لكنني أفتقدك أريدك ،
لا ، نحن بخير ،
بعض من الأقوى  الرجال والقادة
رؤساء وزراء سابقون ،
كان لديهم دائمًا
حضور نسائي قوي للأمهات ،
لكنني أعلم أنني ألهمهم ولكني
أعتقد أنني أتألم بابتعادهم عنهم أكثر
من ابتعادهم عني
ولكني أفعل كل ما في وسعي لجعلهم
جزءًا من  عملي
أتحدث إليهم طوال الوقت طوال
الوقت وعندما لا أكون في واشنطن العاصمة ،
فأنا الشخص الذي أخذهم إلى المدرسة في
الصباح ، وأحب أن آخذهم في
الصباح ، تحدث معهم لمعرفة ما
يحدث
تعلم أنهم يعرفون أنهم يأتون إلي
لإصلاح المشكلات
إذا كانت المدرسة أو أي شيء آخر
يحدث
أنهم يأتون إليّ ،
والدهم هو تعلمهم
دروسًا في الحياة
تاريخنا
وتاريخ العائلة ، الذنب كأم هو
أنني لا أهتم إذا كنت
كيف تكون آه أمريكيًا أفريقيًا لماذا
لا يهم الأمهات نحن الذنب
أننا نشعر بابتعادنا عن أطفالنا ،
لا يزول أبدًا بغض النظر عن العمل الذي نقوم
به رشيد
، وكنت طفلة صغيرة
أتبعها في جميع الأنحاء ، هكذا كانت كاوية
[موسيقى]
متعاطفة متعاطفة
بسيطة جدًا لدرجة أنك تعلم أن نشأتها
ورؤيتها أمي  لم تحكم والدتي أبدًا على ما إذا
كان الرجل في الزاوية وامرأة على
الزاوية قائلة ، أرجوك ساعدني ، أنا بحاجة
لشراء الطعام
، ولم تسأل أبدًا كيف حدث ذلك
لهم ، فقالت إنها أعطتهم فقط
بدون أسئلة
ثم قال والدي  أي شخص يقول
أنك لا تستطيع أن تفعل شيئًا تُظهر له 10
مرات كيف يمكنك القيام بذلك ، فهو قوي جدًا ،
لذا فهي تجربة حية
لرؤية هؤلاء الأشخاص الذين ساعدوني في ترقيتي
ثم تضيف المجتمع الذي
تعرفونه
معًا ، فهذا يجعلني أرغب في ذلك  فاي
بالنسبة لهم وأن أكون أقوياء ، لكنني في
بعض الأحيان أحتاج إلى أن أكون ضعيفًا وأحتاج
إلى الشعور معهم إذا كان
عضوك في الكونجرس يشعر
بألمك ويشعر بالأذى معك ،
فسيكونون أكثر قوة بالنسبة لك
عندما يفعلون ذلك.
لم أكن لأتخيل
أبدًا أن أتخيل فتاة من جنوب غرب
ديترويت
من عائلة صغيرة صغيرة
نشأت في مجتمع منخفض الدخل
وحي
أنت تعرف كل النضالات التي ذهبنا
إليها لأكبر سن 14 عامًا.
عضوة الكونغرس في الولايات المتحدة
الآن
أنا الآن ولا أحد يفكر في الأمر
بهذه الطريقة ، لكنني لأنني
كنت أنا فقط ولم أتقبل
أي إجابة ، لا يمكنك فعل ذلك ،
لا يمكنك فعل ذلك وفعلته والآن
أعتقد  لقد غيرت التاريخ إلى الأبد
ولن يكون الكونجرس هو نفسه أبدًا
لأنني هناك
[موسيقى]
أجنبية
لذلك
أنت